what do you make of the others suffering
in the world today
the people there in north korea
so that is part of the
your of your life's work is helping
those people
what do you think about them what should
people know about them
i think that's when i get angry whenever
i think about them
like is your anger directed at
the heartlessness of people the
ignorance of people
like so when i got on north korea
going through all of that and i went to
south korea one day
i was watching television and there's
like
famous korean k-pop stars and crying and
doing some fundraising concerts and i
literally thought i was like oh my god
something is a horror going wrong in
this country why
are these people crying it was cheery
like campaign
and then later was showing that it was
the animal rights campaign
to helping out cats and puppies in the
shelters
yeah do you know anybody she has their
tears like that to another human being
right now
like no right people rather give a
million dollars to save some dolphins
than saving these children why not being
raped in china
and i think i love elon musk i read this
way i love these people want to like go
the moon
mars and like people told them like yeah
you we went to the moon like i did not
know in north korea
but i think that's what upsets me like
why there is not even one single human
with that kind of brilliance in their
brain
they they can't save so much suffering
but nobody does anything
i think that's midnight i feel like
hard to find help in humanity and that's
when i get so upset
because think about like even biden or
trump or obama
they know what's happening north korea
exactly right i mean
we see satellite photos there's public
executions
i mean the u.n says this is the
holocaust happening again
and is it happening if the holocaust
happening again how
why how are you okay doing nothing about
it
but somehow humans are able to okay
nothing anything
and this is like this is hard
like when people say i'm gonna change
the world i want to make a difference
like
it's hard to believe it you know
yeah that we can turn our back to human
suffering at scale when it's right in
front of us i mean that makes you think
about the holocaust
this is just everybody was looking the
other way
yeah because it was almost too hard to
look at it
no it's not it's the easier thing like
that's the thing
i was like here to speak at the south by
southwest few years ago
and like they're everywhere talking
about like elon musk project going to
the moon right
we're gonna be multi spec like spacious
i was like
back then i did not even know who he was
so if you're guys trying to go
after this earth you haven't even
explored our earth yet
you cannot go to north korea right now
you haven't explored that part of our
our like planet can we do that first
and then move on explore the
landscape of human suffering like
alleviate suffering in the world there's
um
there's a lot of suffering happening in
africa that has to do with disease and
for some reason it's even though we turn
our back to that kind of suffering too
we still can try to do something about
it
and there's still efforts in terms of
uh health care in terms of medicine in
terms of bioengineering in terms of like
all these efforts to help people from
disease but like
that's almost like converting it into an
engineering problem and trying to solve
it that somehow is easier for us humans
but when there's obvious sort of
non-disease-related
torture of humans we look the other way
yeah whether it's china or it's north
korea
yeah i mean that has to be changed
somehow
we'll have to change that somehow this
is the thing right now like
the china like they bring the xinjiang
vigors right they
like say oh there's a vitamin take it
and then it kills their sperm
and make them not reproduce their birth
rate gone down something 47 to something
in the one year time it's a genocide in
21st century
and they get those people and get their
like organs out imagine if there's
some people who do that with cutie
puppies and cats
there's gonna be insane amount of
product they're gonna destroy everything
and this is like a human nature that i
don't get
why there's so much anti-human sentiment
in this modern world like if you don't
have to like
the the fact that i was saying like the
fact that you care about animals right
is beautiful because you care about
something who cannot speak for
themselves
the fact that we care about animals is
because they cannot speak for themselves
right
they don't have that ability and there
are many people who cannot speak for
themselves right now
and why do you refuse to be the voice
for them
because they're simply being a human and
maybe it connects to us
not being proud of who we are like maybe
i don't know what it is
why do they deny humans this way maybe
they don't like themselves
yeah it's almost um we would have to
acknowledge some dark things about
ourselves in order to start helping
you